I would like to sincerely apologize for
everything I've ever said I apologize to
my friends my followers and everyone
I've hurt and let down I should never
have said those things that I said but I
did say them I'm not the man I was when
I said those things those things I said
do not reflect my values or the man I've
become the man I've become will be
silent just as soon as I finish
apologizing for saying those things I
hope you can forgive this unacceptable
error in judgment I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
it just occurred to me that if I were to
stay silent for the rest of my show this
would be very in keeping with my number
one best-selling political tome reasons
to vote for Democrats a comprehensive
guide but I guess we'll have to talk
before I can remain silent we'll have to
talk about all of the apologies for
things that people have said ten years
ago as the USA Today embraces the
politics of personal destruction also
we've got to talk about the Mulder
bombshell that was not a bombshell
the Muller filings in the Southern
District of New York and the Special
Counsel office memo as well we have to
talk about James Comey all but admitting
that the FBI set up the Trump campaign
to be surveilled Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez is now identifying as a trans Jew
that's actually my favorite story from
the weekend a group of aggrieved
leftists are taking refuge from white
people in Costa Rica which is a very
white country and program students hate
Clarence Thomas but can't explain why
they hate Clarence Thomas we'll get to
all of that more but first let's make a
little money honey where the ring rings
mission is to make neighborhoods safer
today over a million people use the
amazing ring video doorbell to help
protect their homes you know this all of
your cool friends have ring I love ring
because ring allows me to see people
when they come up they ring the doorbell
it could be a delivery guy it could be I
don't know whoever I could be in my
apartment I could be at the Daily wire
studio I could be on a beach in Boca
doesn't matter you can see them it's
also automatically uploaded to the cloud
so if the thief who's coming to rob you
steals your ring doorbell you'll still
have the video you can share it with
people it's a much better version of a
neighborhood watch and it's just so
convenient like the doorbell the
floodlight cameras motion activated
camera floodlight connects right to your
phone HD video two-way audio it's
terrific if the ultimate home security
with ring you're always home save up to
$150 off a ring of security kit when you
go to ring.com slash knowles canada WLA
s ring.com slash knowles can or wles
what is it ring.com slash knowles can of
wles
I've given this out to my friends and I
highly recommend it as a Christmas
present it's really really popular
okay so much to get to today including
everything that I've ever said which I
have to apologize for I'm sorry that I
said it because now we're not allowed to
have any opinions this comes
to us via USA Today there's this guy
Kyler Murray who won the Heisman Trophy
but now what do I know about Kyler
Murray nothing what do I know about the
Heisman Trophy nothing what do I know
about most professional sports nothing
all that I know is the USA Today decided
that on the best day of this kid's life
when he won the Heisman Trophy they were
going to ruin his life by dredging up
tweets that he sent out when he was 14
years old in which he said mean things
about gays or something made a joke
about gay people and now his life has to
be ruined because he said something when
he was 14 that is unacceptable
edie according to today's standards so
his life has to be ruined really awful
they started this USA Today I started
this national shaming campaign and this
was Scott Gleason in USA Today
shameless awful thing dirty rotten thing
that he did this is what he wrote about
the kid in USA Today Heisman Trophy
winner Kyler Murray had a Saturday to
remember but the Oklahoma quarterbacks
memorial a memorable night also helped
resurface social media's memory of
several homophobic tweets more than six
years old no social media didn't help to
resurface it you helped to resurface it
this guy Scott Gleason resurfaced it so
that he could get a lot of clicks on his
article and destroy this kid's knives is
that the best night of this kid's life
and he decided to ruin it by dredging up
six year old tweets that were about how
he was making jokes about gay people now
there are a couple aspects to this one I
can't believe that someone was tweeting
when he was 14 years old I've never felt
older than that that the Twitter existed
for a 14-year old and he was sending out
these tweets they were six years ago who
cares this isn't the only time we've
seen this recently Kevin Hart Kevin Hart
lost his Oscars gig Kevin Hart comedian
done very well for himself become you
know made it all the way up in show
business he was offered the Oscars and
these monsters found a tweet that he
sent out 10 years ago and found jokes
that he told 10 years ago about how he
didn't want his son to be gay and he
likes gay people but he didn't want his
son to be gay
was the joke so the premise of that is
that if a comedian has ever told a gay
joke he is now out he can't be hired he
can't be employed he can't have a show
he has to be ostracized from civil
society can you find me one comedian who
has never made a gay joke can you find
me one human being who has never made a
gay joke or laughed at a gay joke find
me one person on planet earth who hasn't
laughed or made a gay joke
none of course none but it's this insane
Victorian puritanical neo puritanical
behavior that is now destroying this
guy's career kicking him out of the
Oscars obviously the question is who
cares nobody cares we all have to
pretend to care because as the great
playwright William Inge observed if you
marry yourself to the spirit of the age
you will find yourself a widow in the
next so now all of a sudden the worst
thing you can possibly do is make a gay
joke in the old days the worst thing you
could possibly do was make a racial joke
pretty soon the worst thing you can
possibly do is say that men are not
women and women are not men if you
question the transgender movement
already you'll be kicked off of social
media and it's it's constantly changing
they're always changing and if you try
to keep up with that you're going to
fall apart Twitter makes this very hard
because it you you can't see when
somebody said something even I've fallen
victim to this you're looking and you
read through somebody's tweets and it
looks others with Trevor Noah the host
of The Daily Show he made disparaging
comments about Israel and when you see
it on Twitter it looks like he just did
it but he didn't just do it he did it
ten years ago or five years ago whatever
it is and that content that time really
does give you context because it it
means that you can never change
a comedian has to change his act someone
like Kevin Hart has to change his act
and I bet when he was telling those gay
jokes ten years ago audiences were
loving it now audience ISM they might
not love those jokes so he doesn't tell
those jokes anymore or as he says he's
apologized he's a different guy he
doesn't think that way anymore whatever
apology he had to give but in in this
world you're never
allowed to apologize your apology is
never good enough and actually if you
apologize you're probably going to be
destroyed because of it in the me2
movement we saw this the people who
denied got to survive and continuing
their careers
the people who apologized lost
everything Kevin Spacey hasn't been
heard of in 18 months or something like
that he's gone to a desert island
somewhere this is really insane
the worst part of it though the part
that I care about because I said what I
don't really care about these Hollywood
people or whatever it's sad to me but it
doesn't affect my life what affects my
life is that this neo Puritanism from
the left makes conversation terrible
it destroys conversation I've seen this
you know I get invited to various events
that are not explicitly in the
right-wing conspiracy so I'll go out
among everybody else I've got a very
left-wing event sometimes and one thing
I've noticed at events that are
populated primarily by left wingers not
even bipartisan not even people of
differing political views even events
that are almost certainly all left-wing
is the conversation is terrible and the
conversation is not terrible because the
people are uninteresting or have nothing
to say or don't have thoughts about
things it's it's terrible because
everybody is so afraid of being
offensive to imaginary people everybody
is so afraid they're all walking on
eggshells they won't say anything other
than the most banal bland boring
observations they'll talk about the
chicken oh this is good chicken isn't oh
yes I'd like the chicken yeah it's very
good they won't say anything they'll
talk about their cats or something but
they won't talk about anything even
remotely of substance not because they
can't but because they're so afraid of
the mob saying you're not allowed to say
that and it just makes the whole world
bland you know eat look Kevin Hart was
telling a joke about gay people his job
is to tell jokes this this other guy the
Heisman Trophy winner Cuyler Maria I
don't know I sort of on principle don't
want to read his tweets because they
should never have been dredged up in the
first place it was a total hip job but
or
are we now saying that people can't
disapprove of homosexual acts of
homosexuality is that what we're saying
because basically every major religion
for all of history has morally
disapproved of homosexual acts we now
have a culture that is that does not
that actually a dis disapproves of moral
opprobrium period and at various points
throughout all of history there has been
various tolerance of homosexual acts for
a period and I believe in Renaissance
Italy the phrase ela modo italiano the
Italian Way referred explicitly to gay
sex in different parts so there have
been obviously variously variously
tolerant societies in ancient Greece of
course there's the famous debate between
the ancient Roman and the ancient Greek
and they're arguing over who has the
best civilization and the Greek says
well we had we built the Parthenon and
the Roman says well that's true but we
built the Colosseum and then the Greek
says yeah well we invented souvlaki
that's delicious he said well that's
true the Roman says but we invented
pizza ok and then the Greek says yes
well we've i've got the trump card we
invented sex and the roman says yes but
we opened it up to women and this you
know obviously throughout the ancient
world they're all of fun are you saying
that right now you cannot disapprove of
certain aspects of sexual morality of
course not of course you can I want to
hear some guy I want to hear from him if
he says I hold homosexuality and world
opprobrium yeah I want to hear from him
and then some guy who says all sex acts
are great you can do whatever you want I
want to hear from that guy and some guy
who defends polygamy or some guy who
opposes polygamy I want to hear from all
of these things because this informs the
way that I think it allows me to bat
around different ideas and just to get
off of these two specific examples of
Murray and Kevin Hart
forget sex in the first place let's talk
about various political situations let's
talk about institutions let's talk about
various wars various aspects of
diplomacy well I want to talk about
everything that's what the right wants
to do we want to battle around ideas and
pick the best ideas what the left wants
to do is censor everybody from Twitter
to the Heisman Trophy winner all the way
up to the Oscars it's awful
it makes our culture very bland I don't
like bland things I want diversity
before we get to the Muller
investigation which we really have to
cover there are some bombshell non
bombshells that we have to cover we have
got to talk about Oh max the fact is
taking care of your health is a
commitment that can feel overwhelming
that is why I love Oh max three ultra
pure supplements Oh max three is really
cool right now you can go to try Oh max
calm slash cough fa c OV e fe fe tri Oh
max dot-com / cough FA CE o VF e fe o
max three ultra-pure is great because it
is the purest option no fish burps there
are a lot of omega-3s on the market this
is the purest most concentrated one
nearly 94% high-quality omega-3s its
health made easy you get a tow Max is
sold over 500,000 boxes of ultra-pure
it's a hit has been tested it has been
approved people like it it's very
popular due to its cult following they
even have this thing called the freezer
test challenge if you freeze other
omega-3 supplements you're gonna take it
out it's going to look really cloudy
because of all the filler that they put
in there Omega o max 3 soft gel remains
clear it's that pure comes with a 60-day
money-back guarantee I'll have plenty of
time to try it really feel the Oh max
difference right now try Oh max dot-com
/ cough fa c of e fa fa get a box of Oh
max ultra pure for free with your first
purchase I'm giving you free stuff take
it try Oh max calm / cough fac of the fe
fe cage free box bye max 3 with your
first purchase try o max that comes
Lashkar feffy terms and conditions apply
there was a bombshell Muller filing that
came out right at the end of the news
cycle was on Friday of last week being
reported breathlessly hysterically
they've got Trump it's Muller time blah
blah blah blah blah okay what do we
actually learn from it we learn a few
things the main takeaway that I found is
that the Muller investigation has a
conclusion which is that Trump is a bad
guy and he should be removed from office
I think that's the conclusion that
they've reached I don't think they have
any anything to support that conclusion
yet I think they started there with
their conclusion and they are working
back
they're filling in the blanks the reason
that I think this is that this
investigation was supposed to be about
Russian interference in the 2016
election do you remember that do you
remember that was the whole point it's
the Russia collusion investigation and
now the only hope they have of getting
this guy is on a campaign finance
violation and even that is so weak it's
so thin so let's start with that this is
the best one that they've got their best
foot forward out of the Southern
District of New York filing they said
that referring to Michael Cohen the
president's longtime lawyer quote Cohen
himself has now admitted with respect to
both payments to women to cover up the
affairs with women he acted in
coordination with and at the direction
of individual one and individual one in
these filings refers to Donald Trump
very clearly they say in the filings
they say individual one managed to win
election to the US presidency over
Hillary Clinton you say okay I think I
know who individual one is now Cohen has
admitted that he paid off these women at
the direction and in coordination with
Donald Trump okay maybe he did maybe he
did maybe he didn't I don't know what we
know about this is that Donald Trump has
paid off women for a long time this
doesn't sound like a very good defense
but it actually is because if Donald
Trump paid off the women strictly
because of his presidential campaign and
because he was this was an important
part of his campaign strategy then it
may have been an in-kind contribution to
the presidential campaign and if Cohen
made this in-kind contribution and if
Trump was spending this money they could
have violated certain campaign finance
laws because they didn't disclose the
nature of the donation because Donald
Trump as the candidate he can give
basically as much money as he wants to
his own campaign there's no violation
there the violation would be if Cohen
did it out of his own pocket if he did
if it was his own donation and the the
other violation would be if it wasn't
transparent if they didn't make the
donation clear now the reason why this
is a very difficult case for for the
prosecution is that Donald Trump has
been paying off women
before I was born since I was a little
glint in my father's eye Donald Trump
has been paying off women to avoid
negative publicity and so as a result
you could say this isn't just about the
campaign this is this is just the modus
operandi of the Trump Organization this
that he would be doing this even if he
weren't running for president again all
of this sort of misses the point people
don't go down for campaign finance
violations ex Senator John Edwards
in 2012 he you remember John Edwards he
ran for president against against Obama
and Hillary Clinton in 2008 he got
caught he was using campaign funds to
pay off his mistress and this was a big
scandal this was a much clearer cut
scandal than Donald Trump paying off
these women and even Forex Senator John
Edwards the prosecution couldn't convict
him of the campaign finance violation he
got off in 2012 does anybody really
believe that an ex Senator John Edwards
in a much clearer case no questions of
whether or not you can go after the
president while he's in office or this
or that or Edwards his history of paying
off women if they couldn't even get John
Edwards do we really think that we're
going to undo the 2016 election then
we're gonna remove a president from
office because of a far less clear-cut
version of this violation of course not
but what else about campaign finance
they went after Dinesh D'Souza when
Barack Obama was president they went
after Dinesh D'Souza for giving an extra
$30,000 to his friend Wendy Long a
candidate for Senate from New York who
was never ever going to win I was
working races during that time he gave a
little extra money to her it obviously
made no difference and they threw him in
the clinker they threw him in it he had
to go to a halfway house he was a felon
he couldn't vote Donald Trump finally
pardoned him over nothing over $30,000
but what about the Obama campaign people
don't remember this the mainstream media
don't report on this but the Obama
campaign was caught with nearly two
million dollars of illegal non
transparent donations so during the
Obama campaign for president 1.8 million
dollars of donations where there were
fake contribution dates they were
the legal limits of it they were doing
what Trump is accused of doing or what
Dinesh D'Souza did on orders of
magnitude a higher scale and what
happened to the Obama campaign did Obama
have to go to a halfway house like
Dinesh D'Souza did they threaten to
throw Obama out of office like they're
threatening to do to Donald Trump take
down the whole presidency I know nobody
went to jail
nobody faced virtually any any
consequences whatsoever
the FEC find the Obama administration
$375,000
two million dollars in illegal
contributions the FEC fined him 300 75
grand nothing a drop in the bucket and
why is this one of the arguments against
Trump that you see is they say there are
all of these indictments against Trump
associates there are all of these people
are getting indicted and Obama people
didn't get indicted right Obama people
didn't get indicted that much because
the Obama Justice Department was corrupt
because it was run by Eric Holder who's
a corrupt politician and by Loretta
Lynch who drew Clavin calls blandly
sinister because of that yes that's true
people weren't held to account that's
right the DOJ they didn't go after the
Obama campaign for two million dollars
in illegal contributions gosh I wonder
why I wonder why that is so it's a it's
a totally selective issue whether or not
they go after him but but even then it's
so so weak they're saying because
Michael Cohen pled guilty to a campaign
finance violation that now they've got
Trump they don't have Trump Trump didn't
plead guilty
Michael Cohen's problem is Michael
Cohen's problem if he pled guilty to
something it doesn't matter UMP on it
saying I think that one's the best
they've got basically still it's pretty
weak also pretty interesting in all of
these filings is James Comey then FBI
director admits now under oath that he
used the FBI used the uncorroborated
steel dossier which was funded by
Hillary Clinton and the Democrats as the
evidence that was required to get the
FISA warrants to surveil the Trump
campaign so he's now admitting this
under oath they used an unverified
it wasn't just unverified when they used
it it was unverified months and months
later when James Comey was fired to
surveil the Trump campaign and how did
the steel dossier come around the
Democrats cooked it up they paid for it
and then they used it as the way to spy
on the Trump campaign that is pretty big
news the the only other thing that comes
out of the Muller filing is from the
office of the Special Counsel himself
and I love this one the media have not
reported this one at all from the filing
on Friday quote the defendant meaning
Michael Cohen recalled that a Russian
national repeatedly proposed a meeting
between individual one Donald Trump and
the President of Russia the person told
Cohen that such a meeting could have
phenomenal impact quote not only in
political but in a business dimension as
well
Cohen however did not follow up on this
invitation so in other words if you got
lost in all of that some guy some
Russian guy goes up to Michael Cohen and
says Trump and Putin should meet and
then Cohen blows him off so in the
Muller filing on Friday you actually
have evidence of non collusion it's not
just that you don't have evidence of
collusion you have evidence now of them
not colluding because because Cohen
didn't follow up on that invitation all
of this leads to the question is this
all they've got why is Muller persisting
when he's clearly got nothing on crimes
with Russia and they're going after
campaign finance why is this I think
this is just in the nature of the
Special Counsel or the Independent
Counsel investigations you're
investigating these guys and you just
grow to hate them one you have to
justify all of the money that's been
spent on this investigation and to when
you're digging through people's dirty
laundry
you realize what horrible people they
are I have no doubt that Bob Muller has
read and seen a lot of things that make
him think that Donald Trump is a no-good
dirty-rotten terrible person Trump
himself sort of admits this he says he's
been in dodgy industries he says not
being not being someone who drinks beer
is one of his only good qualities you
know he kind of admits this said he's
had kind of a wild life okay and so what
Muller was trying to do is he is figure
out a way to go back and fill in
the gaps to let him reach the conclusion
that Trump is a really really bad guy
and he shouldn't be in office that is
not enough to undo an election that is
simply not enough to undo a presidential
election so I think for the right
basically this is good news there
they're gonna go after him pretty hard
on this campaign finance stuff it's very
unclear if they can do it while he's in
office it seems they can't do it well
he's still the president so maybe they
could do it once he's out of office but
if he wins re-election the statute of
limitations will have passed so it's a
really really murky business and I think
when you you drill into the specifics
you see how totally cooked up and unfair
the Muller investigation is when you
zoom out that's really where you've got
to look at it and say what is the point
of this what is the point are we looking
at Russian interference in the election
okay why are we talking about stormy
Daniels and how many women Trump paid
off in the 90s why are it's because you
hate him and you want him out of office
not enough that does not justify an
office of the Special Counsel
investigation speaking of women who are
who are throwing inserting themselves
into politics in a strange way
Alexandria Oh Cassio Cortez is now a
trans Jew in case you missed this here
she is is that very very very long time
ago generations and generations ago my
family
the story of the story goes during the
Spanish Inquisition as so many people
were forced to convert on the exterior
to Catholicism but on the interior
continued to practice their faith
continue to be who they were even though
they were pressure to not be bet on the
outside world it's never occurred to me
that Alexandria Cassio Cortes might be a
Jew I've never had so anti-semitic a
thought in my life as to accuse the Jews
of being the people of Alexandria okay
as he of Cortes
it's really awful that this is running
where did she say this she was saying
this at a Hanukah event at Jews for
racial and economic justice so she said
some event for Hanukah for a very
left-wing group of Jews and she's now
decided that she is going to be Jewish
people are making comparisons obviously
to Elizabeth Warren lieth of Warren Oh
cassia Cortes did this in a much smarter
way why is she doing this well because
she said very anti-semitic things in
public she does not seem to be a friend
of Jews or of the Jewish state she
referred to Israel as an apartheid state
I believe or at least implied as much
she referred to the Jewish occupation of
Palestine Palestine of course being the
fictional country to the east of gnarnia
and to the west of Wakanda and so she's
got this kind of baggage on her so she
goes there and says you know my
ancestors were Jews I'm an ethnic Jew is
this true Ida probably not but maybe I
guess she could take a DNA test except
she just probably learned a thing or two
from Elizabeth Warren and she won't do
this but this is the an extension of the
transgender ideology this isn't she can
just say that she is and it doesn't
matter you know Elizabeth Warren came
out she said I'm a Native American she
used it for professional benefit she
used it to advance her career she used
it to pretend that she was the the first
Native American faculty member at
Harvard or or whatever she said and
Ocasio Cortez is not using it in that
way she's just using it in this very
holistic way the way that words don't
they don't mean anything she's speaking
at it at a group of Jews and she says oh
yeah I'm Jewish somewhere back in the
past and and actually the logic of it is
exactly the transgender logic because
she says my ancestors were on the
outside
Puerto Ricans or on the outside
Spaniards or whatever but on the inside
secretly they were Jewish this is a
logical extension of that of that sort
of transgender ideology but the reason I
bring this up is is not to make fun of
her for that it's probably a fairly
shrewd strategy to sort of plant the
seeds in a way that takes away any
accountability to actually be Jewish the
reason I bring this up is because
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez has one of the
greatest advantages in politics right
now which is that she is considered an
idiot this is a big advantage Bill
Clinton and George Bush we're talking
about this once at a they were on stage
of having a conversation between the two
of them on the advantages of being
underestimated President Bush in
different ways from me but both of us me
because I tend to look like I'm real
nice than him because he used to make
fun of himself you always want to be
underestimated by your adversaries he
consistently benefited by being
underestimated and so did I for totally
different reasons this is so true you
see Bush on stage they're kind of
laughing these Clinton is calling him is
saying that he appears to be stupid it's
not very nice but it's true this is
certainly at what Bill Clinton said
there is exactly true Bubba
benefited from being seen as a really
nice guy you know he's not like
Hillary's really I feel your pain you
know that's his whole schtick playing
saxophone on Arsenio Hall real cool nice
guy and Bush benefited from being
perceived as stupid and this was
unbelievable that they called Bush
stupid Bush Yale graduate Harvard
Business School graduate he you know had
a decent career in business at least was
a successful governor of Texas and when
he was in the White House George W Bush
had a game with some of his aides and he
was him
Karl Rove over who could read more books
he's a voracious reader he has clearly a
sophisticated inner life in his
post-presidency he's a painter and not
just a painter he's a pretty good
painter there's that book of all of his
paintings I have it on my coffee table
it's very good even New York magazine a
left-wing outlet admits that Bush is a
pretty good painter he clearly has a
sophisticated inner life and people
thought he was stupid I talked to people
back in the day back when Bush was
president who who were not intelligent
who did poorly in school who did not do
well on tests who did not were not
academically gifted and they said oh I'm
so much smarter than George Bush oh I'm
so much smarter George Bush is an idiot
Christopher Hitchens famously went on
Bill Maher's show and he he joked about
this he said you know your audience is
laughing at jokes about how George Bush
is an idiot anybody can make those jokes
it's a joke for stupid people to laugh
at all of your audience is mooing and
booing and guffawing here and not a
single one of them is smarter than
President Bush and he's right but Bush
benefited from that it really helped him
maneuver pretty well Ocasio Cortez is
benefiting from this she's clearly a
pretty shrewd politician she managed to
get herself elected to Congress at 28
she upended a long-standing incumbent
because she saw an opening she saw that
he Joe Crowley had not been campaigning
he hadn't really gone out there pressed
the flesh made relationships with people
in ten years and so she said I can go in
there and fill that spot she's done it
she's become a darling of the Democratic
Party she constantly attracts press to
herself she's a fundraiser now for the
party she's even been a threat to Nancy
Pelosi one of her first acts going to
Congress was to go protest in Nancy
Pelosi's office this is a shrewd
politician she doesn't know anything she
I don't want to I don't want to be a
labor of the comparison here she's not
like george w bush she's not reading a
lot of books I don't know how
sophisticated her in her life is but
she's a shrewd politician and we're all
laughing at her we shouldn't
underestimate this woman she's pretty
pretty crafty she's pretty shrewd and
she's advocating a terrible vicious
left-wing extreme ideology and I think
some conservatives want to take the
attitude toward her oh ha ha ha how
funny oh tee hee hee and that's fine she
is very funny
we do that at our own peril we should
take this woman seriously in in many
ways because she's been able to advance
herself and her profile and we'll see if
she'll be able to advance her agenda in
Congress I suspect she probably will
conservatives did this with Bernie
Sanders a while ago
Bernie Sanders is a failure in his
public in his private life he basically
never held a job until he got elected to
office and went on the government Dole
he's a Looney tune from Vermont to
socialist you know he visited the Soviet
Union to vacation I think he honeymooned
there and so we made fun of him
the man nearly got the Democratic
nomination for presidency in 2016 these
things these things can happen fast
these extreme political swings can
happen very fast so we should shoot we
should watch out for her
trans Jew Alexandria Ocasio Cortes who
knows British you might you might be
identifying as a senator soon she might
be identifying as a presidential
candidate if we don't watch it so we've
got to pay attention I've got to say
goodbye to Facebook in YouTube when we
got to talk about the white people
retreat then whatever the white the no
white people retreat white people banned
this is people of color only yoga
retreat in Costa Rica this is what the
intersectional left has given us we've
got to talk about Cabot Phillips is
great new video he went down to the
Savannah College of Art and Design and
all the students want to take Clarence
Thomas's name off a building not one of
them can explain why that is but you've
got to subscribe to daily wire.com what
happens it's ten bucks a month 100
dollars for an annual membership you get
me you get the end of Clavin sure you
get the Ben Shapiro show is this
question for the mailbag which is coming
up on Thursday you have to ask questions
the conversation you get to ask
questions and backstage I mean you get
all of us Vanity Fair did a profile on
us the other day and it said you know
Ben is a Machiavellian hack drew is an
old crank from truth revolt I am a
dapper Lib Trigorin troll and Matt Walsh
is a doer self-described Christian
extremists you get all of that if you
subscribe to The Daily wire so go over
there right now because you'll get your
leftist ears tumblr you will need it we
got a lot more coming up be right back
do you hate white people do you not want
to be around white people anymore then
head on down to the majority white
country of Costa Rica here is the no
white people allowed vacation from the
whites retreat in Costa Rica
Alexis bromley is from Nebraska she
needed a break from white people in
Omaha it's very segregated it's it can
be very isolating if you're a person of
color it's hard in Nebraska because it's
a red state and so you just don't know
who you interact with on a daily basis
if they believe that you're or lesser if
you're inferior and how that in turn can
affect me
she says the current political climate
has only made these feelings worse so
she decided to go on a women of color
healing retreat in Costa Rica ah this
beautiful smile thank you guys so much
for coming my blackness is bold my
blackness
my whiteness is beige my Tanis is oily
my whiteness is swarthy I don't know I
could go on and on I love the argument
that she makes the woman there she says
I live in Nebraska and Nebraska is
really segregated and isolating so what
I decided to do is segregate and isolate
myself by going to Costa Rica and being
away from all those damned white people
the the retreat obviously it bans white
people who was it founded by a give I'll
give you five seconds what just describe
to me the sort of person who would found
this retreat I have a five-four
three-two-one
if you didn't name a silly name to
hipster from Brooklyn as the founder of
this retreat you haven't been watching
this show close enough this was
obviously founded by a silk sillily
named hipster from Brooklyn now living
in Costa Rica her name is Satya X that's
her name Satya X and what do they do
with this retreat they do a lot of yoga
proving that Walsh correct that Yoga is
just just pure pay
Gizem you're fairly a cultish ritual but
there's a great irony here because
they're leaving america and they're
going to which is you know how white is
America it's only about fifty percent
white at 60 percent white maybe at most
they go to Costa Rica which is eighty
three point four percent white and
mestizo that's the percentage of
population Black's comprise or
constitute seven percent of the
population it's two point four percent
Indian 0.2%
Asian so they go to a very very very
white place and they won't allow any
white people to be there and they just
focus on how beautiful they are look
listen how condescending that woman was
at the beginning of that clip you saw
she said look at all these beautiful
smiles Wow like she's talking to them
like they're three-year-olds how
infantilizing is that it's so I mean
this is the real danger of this racial
intersectional ideology is that it's so
infantilizing when they say that speech
becomes violence when they say that we
need to separate
we need to Risa grenade the races
because people of color can't even bear
to be around wipe yes they can you can
bear it it's fine everybody can bear it
you can bear speech we can all bear
speech we can all be around people who
are different from us we can all be
around people who look different from us
it's okay
you will be fine you're not an infant
it's what I think it was Michael Gerson
in the Bush administration referred to
as the soft bigotry of low expectations
that's what you're seeing you're seeing
it from people who are coming out of the
most absurd elitist white hipster
culture because that's what this is this
sort of thing leave leaving your country
leaving your job for a little while
going to a tropical place and doing yoga
and just thinking about yourself all the
time and turning in on yourself and how
special you are and how wonderful you
are that is the epitome of white hipster
left-wing Brooklyn culture that's what
it is so I'm not surprised at all that
it was a Brooklyn hipster who founded
the whole thing it is such an irony
though this this awful selfishness how
do you get out of it I think the way
that we get out of this awful culture of
intersectionality is we stop thinking
about our selves
so much a man wrapped up in himself
makes a very small package
indeed stop thinking about yourself stop
thinking about your skin color stop
thinking about how beautiful you are
stop thinking about how special you are
stop thinking about how people are mean
to you and they're not fair and it's
just not fair or red stop thinking about
yourself and start thinking about other
things sort think about how can I make
my community a better place how can I
make my culture a little bit better how
can I make my country better what can I
do for my family and my friends and my
people in my country and how can I be a
productive member of society think about
that think about what you can do not
what everyone else can do for you and
how you are just by being in the world
you will be happier I promise you I
promise you will be happier when you
just sit around and think about yourself
all day you will become despairing
depressed and miserable but if you do
something on the world you won't be I
think this has a lot to do with why
millenials are so depressed why they're
anxious why they're miserable
why rates of anxiety and depression and
depression and drugs are skyrocketing
it's because all we're doing is sitting
around thinking about ourselves and
think about our skin and thinking about
how beautiful our smile is stop it stop
it that's so that is the definition of
decadence this is why decadence and
exorbitant luxury can make people
miserable because you're just so focused
in on yourself the world is a bright
beautiful place with a lot of diversity
with a lot of beautiful people who are
black and who are white and to wear this
color and who have different ideas and
who have this thought about religion and
sexuality and comedy and who have a
different thought and embrace the
diversity it's a nice thing you can
either it's this great irony that the
people who prattle on about diversity
all the time are the ones segregating
and isolating themselves embrace the
diversity diversity is a wonderful thing
speaking of just totally homogeneous
thinking Cabot Phillips from campus
reform went down to the Savannah College
of Art and Design because they want
their there there's a petition to rename
a building because it's named after
Clarence Thomas Clarence Thomas a black
originalist Supreme Court justice they
don't like this they want to take his
name off the building Cabot Phillips
goes down there he wants to see how many
of them want the name off and how many
of them can explain
why there's a petition on campus to
remove the name of Clarence Thomas
spring court justice from a building
here what's your thought on the petition
I honestly think he should be removed we
should probably just take his name off
the building it's not that big of a deal
I agree that to get it removed what's
your thought on the petition I agree I
don't think he represents the student
body I would sign it
um I think they'd probably send the
petition and is there anything that you
would point to as something that he's
done that would weren't that good mind
if I get back to you there anything that
comes to mind that he's done that you
would point to is something that you
think disqualifies him and I'm the most
much research on this I just saw a
Facebook petition about it and that's
kind of the extent of it he is a
historical figure though so was Hitler
okay is there anything that Justice
Thomas has done that you would point to
and say that's why we shouldn't have him
I mean not in particular not in
particular because I can point to a few
things that Hitler did as reasons for
which we shouldn't name a building after
Hitler I can point to at least a few
things that he did talk about
programming I mean talking it is pretty
scary to look at this because all of
them uniformly have the same opinion
Clarence Thomas bad take Clarence Thomas
off building Clarence Thomas no good
mean mean guy why not a single one of
them can say this is that new meme
that's going around of the NPC the
non-player character which depicts
left-wingers is just bland totally empty
headed to Ottomans just going along
without any will or agency of their own
yeah that that's what it is that's what
we're looking at right now that why are
they all so sure that Clarence Thomas is
a terrible guy well one they've been
they've been probably taught it in
school they've been taught that
originalism is bad and Clarence Thomas
especially is bad they've probably been
taught that without any explanation of
why exactly that is but the other and
that person at the end said that there
had been a petition on Facebook and
problem
what happens if somebody sees a petition
on Facebook they see that their friends
like the petition and then they just
decide based on that social proof that
they are going to agree with that
position as well even though they don't
know the opinion itself there is a lot
of mobbing that goes on that which is
important because of social media and
it's important because of of the nature
of politics on campus and for
Millennials really scary stuff I mean I
whether they rename the building or not
they shouldn't rename the building but
whether they do or not just to look at
that back to back all of those people
did certain that they should remain
rename the building none of them could
explain why and they didn't seem even
bothered that they couldn't explain why
really I hope that seeing that would
wake some of them up to say hmm maybe I
should examine my own positions but what
this means is that the the right needs
to reconsider how we persuade people
this is why I'm a huge fan of owning the
libs this is why I advocate it in a
detached way in an academic way it is a
very good strategy because talking to
those people reasoned arguments are not
primarily what they're basing their
opinions on they're not I loved reasoned
arguments as much as the next guy I
loved reasoned arguments that's what
compels me but it isn't primarily what
is compelling those people clearly not
they couldn't recite one reasoned
argument what is compelling them is
culture as Andrew Breitbart said
politics is downstream of culture you've
got to hit them on the culture you've
got to hit them with the meme you've got
to hit them with whatever the tweet or
the or the movie or the TV show or the
or the song or whatever you've got to
hit him on the culture that is what's
gonna lead down to politics it is not
gonna go the other way
there were many reasoned arguments from
how wonderful Clarence Thomas is there
are no reasoned arguments for why he
should be removed from a building or his
name should be removed from a building
but that part comes later you've got to
hit them first because these this
generation of people is not being
convinced primarily by the arguments
before we go Pope Francis wants to
rewrite the Lord's Prayer this is very
frustrating the Lord's Prayer the Our
Father prayer our Father who art in
heaven hallowed be thy name
they specifically want to rewrite at the
end where it says and to lead us not
into temptation by
deliver us from evil and Francis it
suggested that this be rewritten a while
ago he said it was a bad translation he
said that the lead us not into
temptation is a bad translation because
God would never lead us into temptation
so it must be a wrong translation they
never make an argument from the original
Greek text which makes it clear that God
is the one being referred to as a
leading into temptation but what Pope
Francis said then was quote a father
doesn't do that he helps you get up
right away what induces into temptation
is Satan so he wants to rewrite it to
say abandon us not into temptation and
this is a terrible idea the the word in
question here is in the Greek I'm gonna
butcher it is pear Rasmus temptation it
can mean temptation it can mean trial it
can mean testing and so what what is
being said is lead us not to the trial
lead us not to the testing lead us not
into temptation it is referring to God
we are asking God not to lead us not
this current suggestion says that only
Satan can lead us into temptation the
reason we know that that isn't true is
because we find the Lord's Prayer in the
Gospel of according to st. Matthew in
Matthew chapter 6 two chapters earlier
in chapter 4 Jesus is led by the Spirit
to be tempted by the devil in the
wilderness it's the devil doing the
tempting but it is God the spirit doing
the leading two chapters before we get
the Lord's Prayer and the people who
want to change this want to change it
because they feel uncomfortable with the
notion that God can lead us to a test or
to a trial or to be tempted but it is
clear from the Greek and it is clear
from the from two chapters earlier in
Matthew that that is the case seems a
really bad idea to to rewrite a prayer
known as the Lord's Prayer he doesn't he
doesn't like it when we contradict him
and the reason that this is gaining
traction is because of widespread
theological illiteracy and and apathy
but we shouldn't do it I even some
conservative Catholics and Christians I
know said oh what's the issue that this
to make sense God shouldn't lead people
into temptation okay I see why that
intuitively makes sense to you but that
doesn't make sense from the text there's
a reason why every translation every
major translation of this uses the
phrase lead us not into temptation we'll
see how that is received by the Catholic
Church and by Christians Protestant
Christians more broadly as well but not
not a great idea we'll have to add we'll
have to have some prelate saan soon to
ask them how this is going to be
instituted that's all just rewriting
just rewriting the Lord's Prayer that's
how well then today a lot more to get to
we'll do it tomorrow in the meantime on
Michael knows this as the Michael Nolt
show we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018